phase four of the MCU will officially
begin on May 1st of 2020 but we all know
that the hype has already started and
although it technically starts with the
release of the movie we all know that
for us it will start when the first
trailer pops out and luckily for us we
now know when that date is going to be
what's up everyone it's Warren and the
Black Widow trailer is going to be the
start of hype that we have not seen in a
very long time yes we are all super
excited already and yes we do get leaks
and things to pop up from time to time
but this is going to be the first
official thing that we get from Marvel
about phase four so if you followed my
channel since before Avengers in game
you know that I track trailers the
Avengers in game trailer was a huge deal
nobody knew when it was going to be the
Russo brothers were being very quiet
about it but the fans were making an
uproar and that's what we now have for
the Black Widow trailer fans are
demanding the Black Widow trailer and
just like for Avengers in game it was
first narrowed down to a couple of weeks
and then it was narrowed down to a
particular day which is what we have now
for the Black Widow trailer so for Phase
for tracking and also of course content
be sure to subscribe to my channel to
stay up to date with everything and I'm
doing a giveaway still giving away an
Xbox one or ps4 all you have to do to
enter for a chance to win to subscribe
to my channel with the notifications
turned on leave a like on the video and
comment down below now a few weeks ago I
did a video about when to expect a Black
Widow trailer and I said it was either
going to be the last week of November or
early December well as it turns out it
is being reported right now that it is
going to be early December December 3rd
to be exact and this report is coming
from Daniel RPK who was also the one who
told us about the trailer date for
Avengers endgame now if you recall the
Avengers in-game trailer was actually
pushed back due to the death of
President George HW Bush but after it
was pushed back Daniel RPK did give us
the correct release date when it was
going to drop and it did and today this
is what he has said about the black
widow teaser trailer it will either be
on December 2nd or 3rd no word on which
one is the final date yet but the third
is more likely in the morning so there
you have it again according to Daniel
RPK who was right about the Avengers
in-game trailer we should be getting the
Black Widow first teaser trailer
December 2nd or 3rd but as you mentioned
December 3rd
is more likely if I hear anything else
about it I will definitely keep
everybody up to date and of course I
will do a reaction to it as well I also
have some new giveaway news that I've
been talking about for the past couple
of weeks of course I'm still given away
an xbox one or a ps4 at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers the winner
will get to choose which council they
want but I've also partnered up with G
fuel and we are given away for infinity
shakers four tubs of G fuel and one
Infinity Gauntlet a lot of you have been
stating that you'd still like an
infinity got went over an Xbox or a ps4
so here's another chance to win and also
if you have not tried G fuel yet it is
awesome I just traveled through Europe
for a month and I just drove 34 hours
straight and I could not have done it
without G fuel they have flavors that
you can test on their website just go to
G fuel calm and use code cosmic for
anything you buy and this giveaway is
going to start tomorrow there's going to
be multiple ways you can enter but the
biggest ways to enter are going to be of
course to subscribe to me on youtube and
then follow me on Twitter and Instagram
so tomorrow I'll post the official link
to that giveaway on Instagram Twitter
and of course on YouTube as well let me
know how excited you are for the black
widow trailer to finally come out and
let me know
if you think that somehow she could have
survived Avengers in game
it's Marvel after all so anything's
possible let me know down below and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof